der stern kec 84 62 85 macht etwas sehr
seltsames noch wurde dafür keine
erklärung gefunden bisher der rund 1450
lichtjahre entfernte stern verdunkelt
sich unregelmäßig und so stark um bis zu
22 prozent also ein fünftel dass ein
astrophysiker vermutet dass dort eine
alien zivilisation für die verdunklung
verantwortlich ist jetzt wurde aber eine
neue studie veröffentlicht der eine ganz
andere erklärung für das phänomen hat
was wie wo wieso weshalb warum jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
die schönste erklärung für das seltsame
verhalten von kec 84 62 85 wäre
natürlich eine alien zivilisation
es geht um tabus stern so wurde der
stern nach seine entdeckerin tabea
villarreal genannt
sie beschrieben auch als erster das
seltsame verhalten des sterns verrückt
ist an ihm wie seine helligkeit schwankt
eben unregelmäßig und sehr stark der
stern wird als einer von 150000 sternen
vom weltraumteleskop kepler bei der
suche nach exoplaneten untersucht dabei
wird gemessen ob und wann sich sterne
verdunkeln was auf exoplaneten schließen
lässt geschieht dies regelmäßig immer
wieder gilt ein exoplanet als gefunden
und je nach sternen größe und stärke der
verdunklung der dauer der verdunkelung
der frequenz und weiterer daten können
sogar rückschlüsse auf die größe die
bewohnbarkeit und weitere eigenschaften
geschlossen werden so wurden inzwischen
schon nach heutigem stand fast 3700 exo
planeten gefunden
doch gc 846 25 macht etwas sehr
seltsames der rund 1150 lichtjahre
entfernte stern verdunkelt sich so
unregelmäßig und so stark um eben bis zu
22 prozent ein fünftel das astrophysiker
jason wright von der penn state
university vermutet dass dort eine alien
zivilisation die verdunklung verursacht
ein vorbeiziehender planet könnte nie
und nimmer einen stern so stark
verdunkeln und eben auch nicht so
unregelmäßig seine idee alien mega
strukturen wie die des fähre oder
riesige satelliten schwärme zur
energiegewinnung die wären dann so groß
dass sie das licht des sterns
unregelmäßig abdunkeln bei der weißen
sphäre wäre eine solche abdunklung sogar
was
ähnlich wenn sie allerdings noch nicht
fertig gestellt wäre bei dieser sphäre
hätten die bewohner des stern systems
rund um den stern eine schale gebaut auf
deren dem stern zugewandten seite sie
jetzt leben würden der nähe des äquators
ginge das sehr gut da hier auch durch
die rotation gravitation simuliert wurde
die fläche einer solchen dyson sphäre
wäre hier in unserem sonnensystem zum
beispiel millionenfach größer als auf
der erde eine solche alien mega struktur
könnte die strategie sein um in einem
sternensystem als intelligente spezies
zu überleben allerdings hat die gezielte
suche nach radiosignalen aus auf dem kec
8462 fünf systemen mit city zu keinem
ergebnis geführt wobei es ja sein könnte
dass diese alien zivilisation gezielt
ihre funksignale abschirmt die
entdeckerin tabea pro jahr jahren
startete mitte 2016 ein kickstarter
projekt um den stern genauer zu
untersuchen
mehr als 100.000 dollar kamen zusammen
und mitte des jahres wurde der stern
genauer unter die lupe genommen und
jetzt gibt es ergebnisse gestern
nachmittag kopten überall die meldung
auf und ich hatte ja versprochen dass
ihr es hier sofort erfasst und die daten
machen den stern nicht weniger seltsam
zwar wurde keine diese struktur gefunden
aber staub extrem feiner staub mit einem
durchmesser von weniger als einem
tausendstel millimeter denn nur solcher
staub ist in der lage das zu tun was bei
teppichs stern passiert der stern wird
nämlich nicht über das gesamte
lichtspektrum verdunkelt sondern das
licht unterschiedlicher farben wird
unterschiedlich verschluckt ein planet
in der umlaufbahn könnte zerstört worden
seien also so wie bei star wars und der
staub der explosion würde jetzt für die
verdunklung verantwortlich sein zitat
staub ist höchst wahrscheinlich der
grund warum das licht des sterns heller
und dunkler wird die neuen daten zeigen
dass verschiedene lichtfarben mit
unterschiedlicher intensität blockiert
werden was immer zwischen uns und dem
stern vorbeizieht ist daher nicht
undurchsichtig wie man es von einem
planeten oder einer außerirdischen mega
struktur erwarten würde
das erläutert wo jan allerdings gibt es
ein kleines detail was einfach nicht
stimmt der staub müsste selbst durch das
geschluckte licht aufgeheizt werden
immerhin schlug der ja bis zu 22 er
müsste also
extrem heiß werden doch diese
infrarotstrahlung konnte noch nicht
gemessen werden es bleibt also spannend
rund um tabus stern und er wird sicher
noch für das ein oder andere video hier
auf tricks und sorgen wenn ihr keins
davon verpassen wollt und auch zu allen
anderen themen dann drückt mir hier ein
aber aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr
auch immer über neue videos informiert
hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf
kriegen alien mega struktur aufgeklärt
da gibt es noch eine weitere erklärung
für das geheimnisvolle verhalten von kec
84 62 85 ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran